Princes original recording of nothing
compares to you is here plus our new
music Friday playlist hey guys happy
Friday
I could not head out to Coachella
weekend - without serving up some new
music for you except an extra special
throwback just dropped it's been two
years since we lost Prince and his
estate just released the music icon
original recording of nothing compares
to you it was of course reimagined by
Sinead O'Connor in 1990 and that went on
to be a smash hit
but now the song is widely considered to
be one of prince's greatest songs Prince
did write and record the song in 1984
but it was never released until now
lucky for fans is also accompanied by a
video of unseen rehearsal footage of
prince and the revolution in the summer
of 1984
[Music]
think up
[Music]
[Applause]
[Applause]
I got chills guys and lucky for you the
new version of the song is not only
available to stream and download but it
will also be released as two seven inch
vinyl singles at Prince hit and run calm
all right let's move on to the new new
because brace yourselves y'all ariana
grande is back she took a little social
media break at the beginning of 2018 and
now we know why get your Kleenex ready
because those vocals of her sound better
than ever on her new single no tears
left to cry
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
yeah sorry you know this release follows
2016 dangerous woman album and after the
tragic bombing at her Manchester concert
in May this is a taste of what we can
expect from Ariana's next era I think
we're all in for a real treat okay so I
was out last Friday so forgive me for
catching up but we need to talk about
Zayn new song let me it's also a moody
track and it sounds like the dude is
writing about someone specific you be
the judge
[Music]
did you see that gigi hadid look-alike
in that video well it seems Ain did have
ex girlfriend Gigi on his mind when you
wrote the song he hinted at that when he
called in to Ryan Seacrest to talk about
the new track I wouldn't look I think
that's pretty evident and yeah I was
aspiring to be in love with someone for
the rest of my life than the rest of
that as we all do and things changed we
move forward in life times change but
yeah I was thinking at the time when I
wrote it
Walt times changed about a month ago
when Zayn and Gigi broke up after more
than two years together but why is it
that heartbreak turns into the best
music for Thank You Gigi anyway moving
on to Empire star and king of my heart
just see Smollett he just released this
powerful video for his song hurt people
which he shot in Johannesburg South
Africa at the end of last year it's
something else and I think you guys will
like it take a look
[Music]
hissing clearly people
[Music]
[Applause]
love that our Courtney tez no actually
was with dusty inside his exclusive
listening party back in March for his
album some of my music and clearly the
record was a labor of love literally and
then was there any songs that were
inspired by your past or present
relationship yes
insecurities of course is obviously
inspired by real life they all are but
definitely haha I love you is about is
about someone special to me and and are
you in love with that special someone
right now very happy thank you okay
Jesse we're happy if you're happy
all right guys that's it for this week
thank you so much for watching I am
heading back to the desert for round two
of beach Ella and I'm taking Monday off
to recover I'm not sorry about it so
we'll be back with a new daily deni on
tuesday queen bee she about this thing
so make sure you're following me at d
director on instagram and have a great
weekend guys
[Music]